President Clinton ended his two terms
with 78 million pages of official
records President Bush had 40 million
Pages President Obama 30 million
transcripts letters tweets photos
classified documents all of these are
supposed to go to the National Archives
supposed to FBI agencies classified
records from former president Trump's
home classified documents from President
Biden's time as vice president now the
justice department is investigating why
and how classified documents got to the
home of former president Donald Trump
and to the Home and Office of President
Biden after he served as vice president
here's how records are handled when a
president leaves office and how some
might fall through the cracks
legally the president or Vice President
are the custodians of public records
they create while in office and on the
last day of their term they are supposed
to move all of it to the National
Archives when you walk into the White
House after a new president is elected
the white house is empty the offices are
empty the computers are wiped clean
there's no documents there's no files
it's just empty David marchick has
written about the history of
presidential Transitions and was
involved in President Biden's transition
in 2020 and worked in Clinton's 1992
White House I was young and I had a lot
more hair
when those literal boxes of records are
moved the archives become the custodian
even for things like the president and
vice president's social media accounts
the archives keep all of the classified
documents in a secure location and keep
the rest out of former president's
Presidential Library or a storage area
until it's established at President
Kennedy's Library you can see his notes
and doodles from meetings at the Cuba
Missile Crisis at President Reagan's you
can see artifacts from his attempted
assassination at President Bush's you
can see his notes from his speech
announcing two airplanes
have crashed into the World Trade Center
in an apparent terrorist attack on our
country
preserving a president's records is a
big deal it's the law
and it's also important so that future
researchers Scholars historians
documentarians can get access to these
documents to document history to learn
from president's successes and mistakes
and to avoid those mistakes in the
future which is why it's a law that
every record that deals with the
president's work in office must be sent
to the archives but it's the president's
staff that is actually in charge of
doing that this is where things can get
messy the archives just offer guidance
they aren't checking these boxes leaving
the White House the challenge is people
in the White House work up until January
20th National Security issues don't stop
because there's a new president these
people are busy they're exhausted
they're trying to figure out their
future they're trying to do their
current job and you add to that the
burden of preserving all their documents
it's a lot a person familiar with the
classified documents found on premises
used by Biden told the Wall Street
Journal that one was related to a trip
to Ukraine he took a few days before his
vice presidential term ended it was just
one stop in a hectic travel itinerary
during the last two weeks before the
transition I'll be Vice President of the
United States for 48 more hours when a
president travels their staff goes with
them that means the staff's not in the
office to preserve the records and it
just adds to the challenge it adds to
the pressure and it reduces the amount
of time staff has to preserve their
records Trump's last days were also
chaotic not because of travel but
because he was in the middle of his
second impeachment AIDS at the time said
they delayed packing because of Trump's
attempts to overturn the election the
White House also typically sends records
to the archives throughout the
administration as they are done with
them so it's not a scramble to send all
four years of Records all at once an
archives official said at an event in
January of 2021 that didn't really
happen with Trump usually by transition
time we've got the paper we've got a
majority of the paper records already in
our physical custody we really couldn't
start picking up until January if you're
part of a white house where the
president has lost the election it's a
little more chaotic a little more
stressed and staff start to start to
thin out during this transition period
and so the people that are left there on
January 20th at noon are usually a very
very few people standing and they have a
big burden typically if presidential
public records are found after the end
of a presidency their return to the
archives but they're not normally
classified Trump's records investigation
centers around a number of different
kinds of Records not just classified
ones the investigation only began when
the archives realized they were missing
important ones like correspondence
between Trump and North Korean leader
Kim Jong-un Trump's team failed to hand
those over resulting in a search that
led to the discovery of numerous
classified documents
Biden's investigation focuses only on
classified documents that were found at
a private office and his home while the
justice department is investigating any
wrongdoing the archive's goal has
remained the same make sure they have
all these public records
[Music]